[Music]
straight ahead on long crime daily
surfside victims to receive payments for
housing and funeral expenses
nearly a dozen lawsuits now filed
against the condo association
as the search efforts move from rescue
to recovery
they've searched for void spaces and
they've searched for victims
and why the judge who sentenced derek
chovin is now being asked to rewrite
his legal analysis minnesota's top
prosecutors saying children who saw
george floyd die
were traumatized plus a trial within a
trial
the case against robert durst is heating
up as the defendant's own past testimony
from another murder trial
is being used against him really my best
friend goes
way back then was dead and
the remains of a missing 13 year old boy
led to more clues
a forensic pathologist weighs in on how
dylan redwine died
as his father stands trial for murder
the man of death was homicide
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
in serve side florida the search and
rescue mission at the building collapse
has turned into a recovery operation but
as bodies are continuing to be pulled
from the rubble
survivors and loved ones are turning to
the courts looking for answers
we have truly exhausted every option
available to us in the search and rescue
mission
a tribute to the lives lost in surfside
first responders standing side by side
pledging to carry on their recovery
efforts they've used sonar
cameras dogs heavy machinery
they ran into a building they were told
could collapse
and they braved fire smoke torrential
rain
and strong winds in the hopes of finding
people alive
seven million pounds of concrete and
debris removed now taken in as
evidence with our partners and this and
our homicide detectives our engineers
are on the scene they're
tagging relevant information data
evidence collating it and transporting
it to a site for later analysis
two weeks after the collapse the
miami-dade state attorney says
members of a grand jury have agreed to
look into how to prevent another similar
disaster
our homicide detectives are crime scene
investigators
have been from day one working hand in
hand with our
fire rescue personnel and our medical
examiner's office
more families and survivors are filing
claims against the condo association
four new wrongful death lawsuits have
been filed this week against champlain
towers
bringing the total to at least 11. at an
emergency hearing on wednesday in one of
those cases
a judge filed an official order for
payments to begin immediately
we were able to bring in the receiver
who is
managing the condominium funds from this
point on
and he was able to provide information
to the survivors of what they can expect
and how to move forward and what what is
going to be required with that of them
what they can expect to receive and also
how they can participate in
the hearings that the judge is doing on
their behalf
families who have lost loved ones and
residents in need of temporary housing
will each receive up to ten thousand
dollars
two thousand dollars will be provided to
cover funeral expenses
the point is to get them back and to
help rebuild their lives
late last sunday a judge denied an
emergency request by a resident at the
towers
that didn't initially collapse to allow
her to enter her unit
the woman saying she believed her
emotional support animal was still
inside
wanted to try to retrieve it and offered
to surrender any liability if she was
hurt in the process
hours later the remaining structure was
demolished
here with us today is miami criminal
defense attorney gigi gonzalez and terry
austin
gigi you're in miami how was the
community reacting to the collapse
of this condo south florida has been
completely distraught following this
tragedy uh everybody knows somebody or
knows somebody who knows somebody who is
victim
to this tragedy and the stories have
been absolutely unbelievable
we've had firefighters who recovered the
bodies of their family members inside of
the rubble
they have been searching for you know
survivors or for
victims for days on end in the face of a
very serious uh hurricane tropical storm
here in south florida
it's been a really bad vibe here in
miami and you know our hearts just go
out to the victims and
it has been amazing to see our community
rally together in the face of this
tragedy
absolutely thank you so much for that
gigi terry with nearly a dozen lawsuits
and more expected to come
how is the judge going to manage all of
this litigation
you know it's interesting brian the
proceedings are moving forward
very quickly gg just mentioned that
everybody is pulling together
and that even includes the attorneys for
the receivership
and the condo board they recognize the
fact that they have to pull
all of the assets together and they're
working together to take the 48 million
dollars that's available in insurance
funds and separated out into claims like
burial claims
or property claims or claims for
wrongful death and they do
at the end of the day recognize that
nothing will really compensate these
individuals
but they have to do their best to make
sure that they soften the pain so
everyone is working together including
the attorneys
thanks terry turning now to other top
legal news making headlines
ex-attorney michael alvante avenatti
sorry
has learned how much time he'll spend
behind bars for extorting nike
the former attorney was sentenced to 30
months in prison for attempting to
extort the athletic company
out of 25 million dollars in the hearing
judge gardev said quote
mr avenatti became drunk on the power of
his platform or
when he perceived his platform to be
avenatti is scheduled to stand trial
next week in california
on charges of defrauding clients out of
millions of dollars including one who's
a paraplegic
and next year he's set to go to trial
for allegedly swindling stormy daniels
out of 300 thousand dollars
a judge has ruled that some former
clients of now disgraced attorney tom
gerardi
can pursue their collections lawsuit
against his estranged wife
erica jane the real housewives of
beverly hills star is accused of faking
her divorce
from her husband of 22 years amid
accusations gerrardi embezzled millions
of dollars
from a fund intended for lion air crash
victims
according to court records three of
gerardi's former clients will be able to
collect
11 million dollars owed by him for
previous litigations
hours after the ruling jane posted a gif
of herself on instagram
with a caption the ice queen can take it
interesting turn of events there for the
ice queen still ahead of law and crime
daily how robert durst's own words from
his first trial
are now being used against him but first
how dylan redwine died
the medical examiner takes the stand as
the 13 year old's father is on trial for
murder
the testimony you don't want to miss
next
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back a forensic pathologist
testifies in the trial of mark redwine
that he doesn't know how dylan redwine
died but he's certain it was a homicide
law and crimes and jeanette levy is here
with that testimony
brian dr robert kurtzman was involved in
this case to give an opinion
about how dylan redwine died
dr robert kurtzman testified he examined
dylan redwine's bones including his
skull
to try to figure out how the 13-year-old
boy died
i can't honestly say i would know the
cause of death
all the organs are gone the skin is gone
all the soft tissue is absent but dr
kurtzman said the circumstances
surrounding dylan redwine's
disappearance and death
including the fact that dylan's blood
was found under a rug
in the home led him to one conclusion
the man of death was homicide
dylan redwine disappeared on a
court-ordered visit with his father mark
over thanksgiving 2012.
part of dylan's remains were found seven
months later but his skull
found in 2015 would lead to clues about
how dylan died
there was a fracture in the skull dr
kurtzman said fractures that happen when
someone is alive will heal
but in this case so in the bones that i
looked at with regards to bill and red
wine
there had been no healing process dr
kurtzman testified the skull fracture
happening around the time of death led
him to conclude dylan's death was a
homicide
the cause undetermined he showed jurors
the fractures
in dylan's skull this can be associated
with blunt force injury
now under cross-examination dr kurtzman
like other experts in this case said
that there was evidence that
animals had left markings on dylan
redwine's skull but he said of course
that happened
after dylan died not before or around
the time that he died he also
said that there was evidence of cut
marks on the skull
and he said that was likely made by a
knife kurtzman added that bears
do not carry knives brian thanks
internet let's bring back criminal
defense attorney gigi gonzalez and terry
austin
terry the forensic pathologist can't
definitely say what the cause of death
is
but says it's a homicide how significant
is that for the defense
you know it's very important that the
forensic pathologist can at least
establish the fact that the manner was
murder or homicide because the reason is
here he can tell from looking at that
skull
that the injury to the skull had not
healed and so
he died as a result of that injury and
so the the
manners of death as we all know is
either murder suicide
accident natural or undetermined and
he's determined because that skull
injury had not healed that the manner in
fact
was homicide so that's very important
and as far as the defense is concerned
even if the exact cause isn't known
that is an important factor and that is
going to hurt the defense
my defense uh senses are tingling uh you
can't tell me cause of death but you can
determine
the manner of death do you think that
the defense can put on their own expert
to try to
create a little reasonable doubt there
yeah
absolutely and they should because if
they are able to establish that these
injuries to dylan's skull were caused by
anything
other than homicide then that will
absolutely raise reasonable doubt
and the fact that the coroner here could
not determine a cause of death only a
base his assumptions on the
circumstances of his death
would really help the defense here so if
they can get an expert to come on the
stand and say
that this boy did not die from blunt
force trauma but from something else
it would definitely be helpful to the
defense yeah maybe it doesn't happen
before he died maybe it happened close
in time we'll see how
an expert may be able to describe that
if the defense does that uh and jeanette
an investigator
also testified about mark redwine and
that 2013 search
of where part of dylan dylan redwine's
remains were found
what exactly did he say yeah the
investigator his name was tom cowing and
he actually
testified that as they were hoping to
search middle mountain
as the snow was melting in june of 2013
it had melted they wanted to get up
there to search
because they couldn't before then he
said that he tried to email and
call mark redwine and he received no
response finally he said that a day or
two before the search started
mark redwine finally answered and said
he hadn't been in touch or heard from
or you know hadn't answered because he
dropped his sync his phone in his sync
and the phone was damaged
he said that the other family members
including dylan's mother and brother and
stepfather took part in that june
2013 search where the partial remains
were found
but mark redwine didn't but he said when
he notified him that some of the remains
had been found that
mark redwine started to cry interesting
testimony we'll see how it all comes
together
as this case develops and will continue
to follow it make sure to check the law
and crime network for gavital gavel
coverage
of the dylan redwine murder trial where
his father mark redwine is on trial for
his murder
coming up on law and crime daily george
floyd's family attorney to represent
a familiar face plus the murder of
george floyd and the children who
witnessed it
why minnesota's top prosecutors is now
asking a judge
to reconsider his legal analysis for how
those minors
impacted derek shogun's sentence next
[Music]
we're back the family of a bystander
killed during a minneapolis police chase
is now being represented by the same
attorney who represents george floyd's
family
civil rights attorney benjamin crump
announced he has been retained by
lanielle fraser's family
police say fraser died tuesday morning
when an officer pursuing a carjacking
suspect
accused of multiple robberies collided
with a vehicle at an intersection
fraser was the uncle of darnell fraser
the young woman who filmed the video
of george floyd's murder seen around the
world
turning now to the george floyd case
minnesota attorney general keith allison
is asking the judge to modify derek
chovin's sentencing memorandum
judge peter cahill sentenced chauvin to
22 and a half years in prison
cahill departed from the state's
guideline but for one less aggravating
factor than prosecutors had hoped
four children were present and testified
at trial cahill ruled prosecutors
presented no
evidence the minors were traumatized by
witnessing the murder
and therefore their presence at the
scene is not a substantial and
compelling reason for a higher sentence
ellison disagrees and wants cahill to
change his legal analysis on the record
alison is not asking for cahill to
modify chauvin's sentence
back with us as criminal defense
attorney gigi gonzalez and co-host terry
austin
terry this motion the psychiatrist cv
and the request
seems straightforward and on point do
you think judge cahill will agree with
the prosecution
well you know i read the motion and
looked at the cv it was quite impressive
but
i think the judge will be sympathetic
but i don't think judge cahill is going
to change
his mind he said that the prosecution
did not present
evidence showing that the minors were
traumatized now of course
they did testify but there was no
cooperating evidence
saying that they were actually
traumatized so he didn't apply that as
far as the higher sentence is concerned
so i think at the end of the day he's
going to read the papers
he'll be sympathetic but he'll keep the
decision because at this point
it really is moot they're not asking to
hire the sentence so
it's probably a moot point it's gonna be
interesting to see how that plays out
maybe the prosecution's laying the
groundwork
for future litigation to show that this
is a factor that does apply
gigi it's not going to affect the
sentence as terry says
so do you think nelson eric nelson the
defense attorney for
derek shovin will or should even reply
to this motion
you know i don't think he should but if
he does reply i think at most he's going
to adopt his arguments that he made
for sentencing again this is not going
to affect the sentence it's not going to
lower it or raise it in any way it's not
going to be modified but it may affect
derek shovin's status in prison if he
continues to
uh assert that children were not
traumatized by this event so
you know it might be to the defendant's
benefit not to respond to it but
the attorney here has a duty to his
client to
zealously advocate for him so we may see
a response from nelson in this case
yeah it'll be interesting to see how
judge cahill responds and also
his understanding that because he did
take a bit of a procedural standpoint
he didn't say that the children were not
traumatized merely that the prosecution
didn't present the evidence
so maybe this presentation of the
evidence changes that equation
of course we'll follow this and give you
updates as that comes up when we come
back
the latest in california versus robert
durst how reenacting a previous trial
can bring up some relevant evidence for
this trial
welcome back now to texas i mean
california
where the robert durst trial continues
with transcripts from the morris black
murder trial the real estate air is
accused of murdering his best friend
susan berman
in december 2000. robert durst was
previously accused
of the murder and dismemberment of his
neighbor morris black while he admitted
to the dismemberment he was acquitted of
the murder by claiming self-defense
these are durst's own words of when he
allegedly found out that his best friend
was murdered
i should go to the l.a times on the
internet
that susan berman had been murdered
over christmas what did you think
i i
i felt terrible for susan and
terrible that really this
really my best friend goes way back then
was dead durst then goes on to describe
how he learned that he was a possible
suspect
he says that when he fled to galveston
texas
his response was that he was getting
calls from reporters that susan berman
robert durst's good friend was murdered
in san francisco over christmas and
janine
pirro had spoken to the press and is
i can't remember the word that he used
but is saying that you are not aiding
and abetting or
some other legal term for it so janine
pirro now you have just learned of the
death of your good friend the murder of
your good friend and shortly after
that janine pirro is claiming that you
are involved seemingly
janine pirro was claiming yes
it was in galveston texas where robert
durst met his neighbor morris black
the two got into a fight where durst is
said to have accidentally fired a gun
and killed morris black i went to pull
the gun
and the gun didn't move he moved
and the two of us fell back like that as
you hit the ground
or the floor and as your
elbow hit what happened the gun went off
bam like that like that
the course the court also read the
transcript from when durst openly
admitted to dismembering and dumping
black's body
several saws
an ax and hammers
and other stuff like that and i
got this idea that the
body rolled up in the drop cloth
that i was going to cut it in half
mr durst did you
during the course of that day dismember
mr morris black's body
yes sir what did you do with the parts
of the body
i put them in garbage bags did you throw
them all in the same place
there yes sir
all right let's dissect this trial
within a trial gigi
where is lewin going with this durst was
acquitted of murder
could be suggesting that maybe the
reason why we can't find susan berman
is because durst got better at
dismembering this time around
you know possibly i think it's a really
interesting angle that he's taking here
but the reality is you know if robert
durst admitted to dismembering the body
here
and the other bodies were not
dismembered then wouldn't that lead us
to believe that robert durst
if he has a habit for kill for
dismembering people that he's killed
he would have dismembered the other
people that he's allegedly killed
so you know i don't think the state's
going to go that far if you really start
to think about it
with common sense terms yeah but this
prosecution is so
broad in its theories and its angles
it's going to be fascinating to see
where ada lewin ends up in terms of what
angle he wants to attack
consummation terry is there anything the
defense can use here
or is this showing a pattern of death
just surrounding robert durst
well there's no question that death is
surrounding robert durst it definitely
hurts the defense here
you know durst was acquitted of
murdering black but he's admitted that
he's dismembered him
and to me that shows a depraved mind it
shows consciousness of guilt and i think
that's exactly what the jury is going to
be thinking
here so we know that the wife's body was
never found
we know that black's body was you know
dismembered
and we know that susan berman was shot
and her body obviously was found
but i think at the end of the day what
the jury is going to be thinking about
is we know that durst has
a habit of covering things up and we
know
that death is following him so all of
this damaging
information is going to affect the
verdict at the end of the day
we'll see how that plays out long crimes
got cameras in the court for you for
gavin gavel coverage
thanks for joining us here on law on
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss justice
in america
[Music]
you